while there's nothing unusual about a
box office bomb it's not often that they
take a whole studio down with them but
that doesn't mean it doesn't happen
believe it or not it's a wonderful life
wasn't always a beloved Christmas
Masterpiece this Frank Capra classic
Stars James Stewart as George Bailey a
suicidal man whose Guardian Angel shows
him all the people he's helped and what
life would be like without him today
it's a wonderful life is a ubiquitous
Christmas movie that's broadcast every
year and it often appears on lists of
the greatest films ever made things
weren't so Rosy back in 1946 however to
my big brother George the richest man in
town Liberty films produced the film for
$2.3 million that's some $36 million
when adjusted for inflation when all was
said and done however it made only about
$2 million at the box office Liberty had
been founded by legendary filmmakers
cpra William Wier and Samuel J briskin 2
years earlier making its a wonderful
life these Studio's first first film
their initial plan to produce 15
pictures ran a foul with reality and
Liberty couldn't cope with the financial
loss When It's a Wonderful Life bombed
at the box office it took the studio
with it facing foreclosure Liberty sold
its assets to Paramount Pictures and
shut its stores the three founders
cashed Liberty and its assets in for
Paramount stock and took jobs at the
studio still it wasn't all bad despite
the movie's Financial Failure Its
wonderful life was nominated for five
Academy Awards including best picture
and Best Director the 19 60s was a great
decade for Hollywood epics but not all
of them performed as well as those that
had been produced in the ' 50s still the
decade plowed on with several notable
titles including 1964's the fall of the
Roman Empire the film's title kind of
gives away the plot in fact it's a loose
adaptation of Edward Gibbons the history
of the decline and fall of the Roman
Empire at first the one thing the film
had going for it was the involvement of
Charlton hon who is all but a
requirement for historical epic to
succeed unfortunately hon backed out
before production began began leaving
Steven Boyd to take the role of lius in
his stad at the same time production
costs ran as high as any other epic
amounting to $9 million or about $187
million today unfortunately audiences
weren't particularly kind to the fall of
the Roman Empire resulting in a box
office total of around $4.75 million as
such producer Samuel Bronson's company
Samuel brunston Productions didn't
survive the loss the company ceased
business in 1964 the same year the film
was released and entered into bankruptcy
James Cameron's Titanic may be the most
well-known film about the infamous ocean
liner but it was hardly the first I'm
the king of the
world the RMS Titanic had been a source
of speculation and Intrigue since the
ship went down and naturally it has also
been the focus of numerous films one of
the most expensive was Raise the Titanic
based on Clive kusler's novel of the
same name the plot centers around an
effort to recover the ship and obtain a
precious carg Go hidden inside Raise the
Titanic cost ITC entertainment around
$40 million to produce which wasn't even
nearly recovered at the box office the
picture's total haul amounted to around
$7 million and that didn't even pay for
the 55 ft long scale replica of the ship
which weighed in at a whopping 10 tons
cost $5 million to construct and
required a $3.3 million tank to hold it
Lou grade the film's producer told the
independent years later it would be
cheaper to lower the Atlantic than Raise
the Titanic Raise the Titanic was the
last in a long line of bombs released by
ITC films and its Distributing arm
Associated film distribution as a result
ITC was forced to sell afd and the
distribution rights of its library to
Universal Pictures ITC remained in
existence though the company was forced
to sell more of its assets over time
ultimately moving primarily into
television distribution before shutting
its doors for good in
1998 director Michael chimino stormed
Hollywood in 1978 with the deer hunter a
movie that earned him Academy Award wins
for best picture and Best Director 2
years later he followed up the deer
hunter with Heaven gate and almost
completely quashed all the Goodwill and
positive Buzz he'd acquired Heavens gate
tells the story of a dispute involving
immigrants and land barrons in 1890s
Wyoming the film features an All-Star
cast including Christopher Walkin John
Hurt Chris kristopherson Sam Waterson
Jeff Bridges and many other notable
actors the shoot ran into problems
almost immediately and an initial budget
of $7.5 million quickly shut up to $1.6
Million by the end chimino had managed
to bloat the budget to a whopping $44
million Chino's onset Behavior also
resembled that of a straightup
tyrannical dictator bringing negative
publicity to an already difficult shoot
his constant demand for retakes only
upped the budget and after the first 5
days of shooting heavensgate was already
six days behind schedule eventually
chimino finished his project and
Unleashed it upon the world sadly Heaven
gate was not particularly well-liked by
critics and and audiences avoided it
like the plague the film made less than
$4 million at the box office
significantly damaging United Artists
bottom line the long-standing
independent Studio co-founded in the
1920s by Charlie Chaplan then became a
subsidiary of MGM effectively ending its
status as a standalone film company
Superman the movie was an immensely
successful superhero film that proved
that a live-action comic book adaptation
could be done the sequel 1980 Superman 2
was equally impressive but the franchise
began to decline with the third film it
all ended with Superman 4 the Quest for
Peace A much derided final installment
that follows the Man of Steel as he
faces the evil solar powerered villain
nuclear man I want to propose a
toast to a nice guy who's about to
finish
[Music]
last the Canon Group Inc oversaw a
difficult production on the Quest for
Peace the company suffered a financial
crisis mid- production after taking on
too many projects simultaneously this
resulted in budget Cuts requiring 30
minutes of footage be dropped from the
film which greatly suffered as a result
in the end Superman 4 made 36.7 million
on a budget of $17 million which had
been cut down from an initial $30
million despite doubling its final cost
at the box office the film lost money
overall and it was heavily panned by
critics at the same time Canon invested
millions in a liveaction adaptation of
Masters of the Universe which also
bombed commercially and critically Canon
faced bankruptcy and an investigation by
the SEC ultimately forcing its sale to
path Communications it soon fell under
the ownership of MGM but an attempted
Revival resulted in more failure and the
studio became defunct in
1994 there's no denying that the right
stuff is an excellent film the movie
focuses on the founding of the American
space program and the Mercury 7 the
first batch of test pilots shot into
space in the 1960s fronted by a stellar
cast The Right Stuff earned significant
critical Acclaim winning four of eight
Academy Awards
Read It and Weep despite everything it
had going for it the right stuff bombed
at the box office the film cost $27
million and made less than $22 million
it also faced a lot of competition upon
release and a near 200 minute runtime
didn't exactly help get audiences into
theaters the lad company produced the
film which was the last in a long line
of financial failures the company
released up to that point after the
right stuff tanked Warner Brothers
ceased releasing films by the lad
company forcing the studio to search for
a new distribution partner the studio
continued with limited releases and
worked intermittently with Paramount
Pictures and Miramax films before
closing its doors for good in 2007
Aurora Productions began producing
content in the early 80s with the
incredibly successful and much loved
animated classic The Secret of nim
unfortunately the company followed this
with a string of live-action flops not
one of which succeeded at the box office
Aurora paid Millions to produce five
movies you've likely never heard of
before Heart Like a Wheel Eddie and the
Cruisers Maxi Eddie and the Cruisers 2
Eddie lives and finally side out side
out was the last movie that Aurora
produced before closing its doors for
good the film is about a lost student
named Monroe Clark who moves to Southern
California and winds up competing in a
volleyball tournament the film cost
around $6 million to produce and it
raked in just
$450,000 the financial loss was too
significant for Aurora Productions to
overcome and the company discontinued
operations in 1990 shortly after the
film hit theaters for some reason s out
received a retro VHS Blu-ray release in
2022 though this was likely done through
the film's distributor TriStar pictures
Cutthroat Island was notoriously named
the biggest box office bomb of all time
by Guinness World Records a dishonor it
held until at least 2012 Cut Road Island
was intended to be a tentpole film that
rekindled popular interest in the
swashbuckler genre instead it nearly
killed it outright the movie suffered
numerous problems during production
including Michael Douglas backing out
and Matthew modin taking his at the last
minute incredibly expensive sets of
wooden sailing ships were built and then
rebuilt when necessary the initial
budget of $60 million which was high
enough already increased to nearly $100
million by the shoot's end on top of all
that critics tore the film apart
damaging the careers of basically
everyone involved the Production Studio
carolco hoped the movie would succeed
and eliminate its many debts but the
opposite happened Carol Co ultimately
lost an estimated $147 million thanks to
cut Rhode Island utterly destroying the
company Carol Co subsequently agreed to
sell its assets to 20th Century Fox for
$50 million that deal fell through
however when Canal plus outbid fox in
the end cutro Island a movie that was
meant to save Carol Co from Financial
ruin walked the production company right
off the plank it'd take nearly another
decade for the swashbuckling genre to
finally find its salvation you are
without doubt the worst pirate I've ever
heard of but you have heard of me
director ctor and animator Don bluth's
work has entertained children and adults
for decades but his final theatrical
film failed to perform as well as his
earlier movies Titan AE was an ambitious
project incorporating both traditional
handdrawn 2D cell animation and
extensive CGI a relatively new
technology in 2000 the film follows kale
Tucker a man who is swept up in
interstellar Dramatics and soon becomes
Humanity's Last Hope for salvation and
survival Titan AE received positive Buzz
for its bold visual style but mixed
reviews caused trouble when the movie
hit theaters this was the third and
final film produced by Fox animation
which previously released bluth's
Anastasia and Bart talk the Magnificent
due to the increased costs of featuring
new technology alongside the tried
andrue animation methods of the 28th
Century the film cost $75 million to
produce which was quite a lot for an
animated movie back then while Titan AE
has since become something of a cult
classic it bombed at the box office with
only $ 36.7 million in ticket sales 20th
Century Fox killed its Animation Studio
as a result which was at that point
developing a film set in the Ice Age
when operation ceased some of fox
approached Blue Sky Studios and
developed the film that would launch the
ice AG franchise so at least some good
came from Fox animation demise John
Travolta's dream of adapting Elon
hubbert's Battlefield Earth into a film
began in the 1990s when he took the idea
to numerous Studios they all bulked at
the film's connection to Scientology and
the project ultimately landed at the
independent production company franchise
pictures Battlefield Earth revolves
around a human-led rebellion against an
alien race called the cyclos long after
their successful conquest of Earth it
stars Travolta Barry Pepper and Forest
Whitaker Battlefield Earth was an
ambitious picture to say the least and
it cost $80 million to produce in the
end however it flopped hard taking in
less than $30 million in ticket sales
while the Razzy Awards handed the film
The Golden raspberry for the worst drama
of the Razz's first 25 years
oh you're too much as a result franchise
pictures ended up owing its investors
far more than it had in its coffers a
subsequent lawsuit found the company had
overstated the movie's budget by
millions franchise pictures lost its
Court battle and was ordered to pay
entertainment $77 million though a jury
rejected entertainment's claim under the
RICO statute Battlefield Earth has since
become a cautionary tale of the dangers
of aister passion projects Final Fantasy
has long been one of the most popular
role-playing video game franchises of
all time when the series Creator hero
Nobu sakaguchi set out to direct a
computer animated film based on the
franchise fans excitement was palpable
after all this was the series original
Creator branching out into a new medium
so fans were eager to see the result
sakauchi worked with square pictures to
render the film and the result was the
first genuinely photorealistic computer
animated film ever made while Final
Fantasy the spirits within is arguably a
beautifully rendered movie It was not
well received the movie's costs also
increased exponentially during
production amounting to a whopping $145
million the most expensive video game
film at the time the film made a
relatively tidy sum of $85 million but
that obviously came in Far Below its
cost sealing the spirits within's fate
as a box office bomb at the time of its
release square and Enix had planned to
merge but Enix held off following
Square's significant financial loss they
ultimately joined in 2003 becoming
Square Enix but square pictures didn't
survive the spirits within before
shutting down for good square pictures
fulfilled a commitment to create a
10-minute segment featured in The
animatrix Once finished the studio laid
off its 125 employees located in Hawaii
Japan and North America in 1996 Warner
Brothers blew audiences away with Space
Jam proving the studio could blend live
action and animation into a successful
feature film so it was no surprise that
the studio would want to follow up that
success with another and in 2003 Looney
Tunes back in Action hit theaters the
film cost $80 million just as much as
its predecessor unfortunately it didn't
do nearly as well at the box office
while Space Jam took home over $230
million its successor only managed to
Rak in $ 68.5 million initially the plan
was to make a straight sequel to Space
Jam but that didn't end up happening
until 2021 worse still the 2003 release
of back in Action suffered from changes
made throughout production ensuring that
the final product looked nothing like
the original intention the film
certainly didn't blow anyone away and
led ongoing production efforts to cease
at waren Brothers feature
animation Go Home Folks Warner Brothers
feature animation canel the projects it
was developing following the financial
loss from back in action and went
defunct in 2004 Warner Brothers later
reorganized its animation Pipeline and
relaunched it as Warner animation Group
which produced The Lego Movie and space
j a new Legacy the division was rebooted
again in 2023 by Warner Brothers
Discovery this time as Warner Brothers
Pictures animation epic war movies often
attract critical and Commercial
attention but they can be somewhat
cumbersome to make the 2003 adaptation
of Jeffree sher's novel Gods and
Generals proves this as well as any
other film clocking in at 219 minutes
long and that's 280 minutes if you're
watching the director's cut the film is
a prequel to director Ronald F Maxwell's
1993 movie Gettysburg and it booked in
Allstar cast including Jeff Daniels
Robert Duval and Steven Lang remarkably
the first finished cut of Gods and
Generals exceeded 5 hours requiring
significant edits despite all that
trimming the film's pacing proved to be
a serious problem and it ended up
becoming a financial and critical
failure despite a great deal of
historical accuracy excellent production
design and strong performances by the
leads in scope Gods and Generals makes
for an impressive prequel to Gettysburg
but it simply couldn't overcome that
length after failing to Garner interest
elsewhere Ted Turner had financed the
film via his own Ted Turner pictures
this put the $90 million production
marketing and distribution cost squarely
on Turner who lost it all the film
brought in just under $13 million in
total ensuring Ted Turner pictures was a
oneandone company when the film failed
Turner pulled the plug on an adaptation
of last full measure the third film and
the trilogy ultimately Gods and Generals
was the only film made by Ted Turner
pictures the Pang brothers directorial
debut Bangkok Dangerous hit theaters in
1999 and in 2008 they released an
American remake starring Nicholas Cage
while the Thai film from 99 was
relatively successful its successor was
not the film follows a contract killer
in Bangkok as he carries out a series of
hits soon he goes against his personal
code and falls for a local woman C's
filmography is littered with both
well-received films and efforts even his
most DieHard fans would avoid sadly the
Bangkok Dangerous remake turned out to
be the ladder the film was relatively
expensive costing $45 million to produce
even for an action movie that's not an
insignificant amount of money hardly
anyone bothered to see it too and those
who did didn't have much nice to say
about it that's
just Bangkok Dangerous only managed to
earn $42 million at the global box
office making it a certified flop
critics panned the movie for nearly
every aspect of its making including the
action sequences Cage's acting the
direction editing and screenwriting
several Studios had worked to bring the
film to life and only one didn't survive
its release virtual Studios LLC which
previously worked on 300 and V Vendetta
closed its doors in 2009 Bangkok
Dangerous stands as its final film Fox
atomic was an offshoot of Fox Search
light Pictures and 20th Century Fox
designed to produce and distribute genre
films and comedies one of the final
films to Bear the fox Atomic logo was
The Rocker a rain Wilson comedy about a
failed musician touring with his
nephew's band the film features an
Eclectic cast including Christina
Applegate Josh Gad Emma Stone and others
because the rocker was a low-budget
comedy the studio didn't have to pay too
much to put it all together ultimately
spending $15 million on production
unfortunately that made the box office
receipts of only $8.8 million all the
less palatable to Fox atomics bottom
line although it has since become a cult
favorite critics didn't care for The
Rocker at the time nor did audiences or
the ones who saw it at any rate due to
this financial failure Fox Atomic
released its remaining slate of two
films in 2009 and then promptly shut its
doors anything that was still in
production and post- production was
transferred to the parent company and
fox Atomic name was consigned to the
history books animated films have always
been costly due to the incredible amount
of work that goes into making them
computer animated films are no different
and often require more money than
traditional animation due to the costs
of equipment rendering power and the
large pool of talent that brings it all
to life despite this even smaller anim
at films make enough money from a
theatrical release video sales and
through other means to make it all work
Mars Needs Moms was not one of these
films while Disney pictures and image
movers digital produced this movie and
neither company left the theaters
unscathed Mars need's moms failed to
attract any kind of audience resulting
in huge losses for both companies in
fact it stood as one of the most
significant financial losses for a
Disney branded movie upon its release
earning $ 39.2 million off a staggering
budget in marketing cost of $175 million
the house of mouse survived of course
but image movers digital didn't Faire as
well after production ended Disney shut
down the studio phasing out 450
employees over a year as a cost cutting
measure image movers had been the
brainchild of Robert zekus who pioneered
the motion capture animation style in
Mars need's mom's Beowolf and A
Christmas
Carol H buug the closure also ended
zam's planned 3D adaptation of The
Beatles 1968 hit Yellow Submarine
Francis Ford Copa is arguably one of the
greatest directors of his generation but
not all of his films have been
successful one from the heart takes
place in Las Vegas where a couple breaks
up finds Comfort elsewhere and
ultimately returns to one another it's a
musical too making it entirely different
from cop's other work Copa bought the
rights to the property through his
company Zoey trip Studios and personally
financed the film first for $15 million
But ultimately at a cost of $25 million
and that's a heck of a lot for a
romantic comedy released in 1982 koba's
insistence on using expensive Miniatures
and sets meant the movie cost much more
than a typical musical romcom the film
utterly bombed with critics and
audiences too making only
$636,000 Copa had no choice but to file
for bankruptcy the third time the
director had done so in less than a
decade zoy trip Studios didn't die
entirely due to the one from the heart
Fiasco but cop's finances took 10 years
to recover meanwhile Zoey Trope lost all
the good favor earned from Apocalypse
Now And The Godfather films and in 1990
the studio was reorganized into American
Zoey Trope in 2001 new line Cinema
astounded the world with its
mind-blowing adaptation of JRR tolken
the Lord of the Rings trilogy and in the
aftermath the studio decided to continue
adapting High fantasy literature you
shall not pass
shortly after the Fellowship of the Ring
hit theaters new line acquired the
rights to Philip Pullman's His Dark
Materials Trilogy and began developing
The Golden Compass like tol keen's work
pollman's presented several challenges
one of which was cost as the world pman
describes as vast magical and highly
detailed The Golden Compass was
therefore an expensive undertaking but
it had the potential to pay off big for
the production company the movie cost
new line $180 million to develop and
while nobody would call that a small
amount of money it seemed like a good
investment at the time even better
fantasy films did well in the early
2000s All In All The Golden Compass
seemed like a potential Blockbuster hit
for some reason though The Golden
Compass simply never matched the success
of the Lord of the Rings it didn't even
come close in fact the movie made $372
million at the worldwide box office so
while it wasn't quite a total bomb it
did turn out to be a financial
disappointment for the studio new line
subsequently restructured and sold its
assets to Warner Brothers Studios ending
the Studio's prominence after over four
decades in the business Hammer films was
once the preeminent production house for
Gothic horror movies the studio turned
out tons of Classics throughout the 20th
century beginning in the 1930s and
continuing well into the 60s and70s
however the 1970s saw the downfall of
both hammer and the horror genre which
had become oversaturated with cheap to
produce similar content Hammer's tried
and true formula began to falter and the
studio produced a string of financial
failures ending with the lady van ises a
remake of Alfred Hitchcock's 1938 film
of the same name the movie was a risky
proposition to begin with it's not easy
to one up a master like Hitchcock and
Hammer learned this lesson the hard way
the studio paid around £2.5 million to
produce or just under $2 million in
today's money while the final box office
numbers aren't publicly available it
couldn't possibly have been good while
Hammer stopped producing movies in the
wake of the lady vanishes the studio
didn't disappear entirely despite
liquidating in 1979 hammer technically
remained in existence and it has been
bought and sold many times over the
years renowned theater director John
Gore most recently purchased hammer in
2023 but it remains to be seen whether
he can bring the studio back to the
success of its Glory
[Music]
Days